thank you okay well just get this out of
the way right away this is not a talk
about lattices all right okay no I know
terrible right hypocrisy the collinear
we'll see so this is a talk about
interactive coding this is becoming a
more and more active space so I'm going
to feature some works by different
combinations of these people and and and
there's many other interesting works in
the space that I'm not going to have
time to cover but this is mostly to talk
about not about cryptography although we
get to that a little bit at the end but
i do have adversaries so yes what Oh
what is it flows you know okay so hold
on I have to have my my staff help me
with this here
good
good st okay thanks okay so let me tell
you about where the adversaries and
where the noise come up in this problem
so we're thinking about setting where we
have two-party computation so two
parties are trying to compute some joint
function on their inputs so no secrecy
yet they're not trying to hide anything
they're just trying to efficiently
compute some function of x and y and
they're doing this by sending bits back
and forth and some interactive protocol
but now we imagine that we can have
adversarial noise on this channel and
some bits that are sent might be flipped
and in the most general case a sender
does not know that an error has occurred
and hence if we don't do anything if we
just keep running a protocol that was
designed in the in a noise-free setting
the rest of the computation will be
useless so the entire process of the
protocol can depend heavily on the the
transcript submitted so far so as soon
as there's a single bit flip a general
protocol can get the wrong answer at the
end of the computation and in this
setting we're going to consider a strong
adversary who can corrupt a constant
fraction of all the bits sent during the
course of the protocol so we're going to
fix the length of the protocol let's say
going to be a hundred bits I'm going to
give the adversary say ten percent we're
going to give him a budget of ten bit
errors that he can cause I didn't eat at
any point in the protocol so we have a
fixed communication length now if this
was a constant communication length we
could hope to simply put it wrap each
message in an error correcting code but
notice here that if we have a long
protocol that sends many individual bits
and we have a constant fraction of them
can be wrong that we can't simply wrap
each message in an error correcting code
because he could corrupt an entire one
of those messages so if there are M
rounds of communication here and his
budget is greater than 1 over m 4 bits
that he can flip then an adversary can
can defeat just the regular air
correcting coding so we need something
that takes into account this interaction
so this problem was first formalized by
Shulman in 1992 whoo-hoo notice this
fact that 4m rounds of communication if
I only use sort of error correcting
codes designed for the static setting of
communication
I can only achieve an error rate less
than 1 over m so when M is is super
constant we want to get something like a
constant error rate and so our goal is
to get a constant relative error rate
and a constant multiplicative overhead
in communication so if I start with a
protocol between two parties that has em
rounds of sending a bit back and forth I
want something like a protocol that has
4m rounds and that achieves let's say
like a ten percent constant error ain't
so these are the these are the
parameters that I'm that I'm trying to
achieve so I hope you'll forgive my
highly professional slides here that I
that I that I drew on this just to give
you an idea of what these things look
like so we can express the protocol as
as a tree so the most basic way of
looking at this is Alice speaks and
sends a bit which is a function of her
input why it's either 0 or 1 that puts
us at a new node in the protocol tree as
a function of where we are in that tree
and of his input so Bob speaks is the
function of his input X and send 0 or 1
and we can think about executions of
these protocols as passed down this
protocol tree so the depth of it's a
full binary tree where the depth is an
is the number of rounds of communication
so if we think about execution of the
protocols with no errors we're simply
sending bits and traveling down the tree
and we're traversing exactly exactly one
path of this tree so both parties have
this internal state that they know what
the transcript is so far they know what
they sent they know what they received
if there are no errors and there's
perfect agreement as to where the two
parties are in the protocol tree and
they simply take a path down and reach a
leaf and at the leaves are the answers
to their computation so once we are at a
leaf there's a determined function of
the transcript that produces the answer
to whatever computation they wanted to
compute so yes so you're only sending
one bit for message is that yes so I'm
assuming which is without loss of
generality under certain regimes of
which parameters I care about that each
message is only one bit when messages
get longer interactive coding tends to
get easier at least quantitatively
because I get more protection out of
wrapping a long message in an error
correcting code than then relative to
short messages so sort of the worst case
for us is one is one big communication
okay so a path in the tree corresponds
to a transcript of communication but
when we're trying to simulate such a
protocol under errors what we end up
doing is we end up having diverging
views of where we are in the tree so
when we have Alice trying to send zero
and it gets flipped to a one without her
knowledge then what happens is suddenly
we don't have sort of one marker of
where we are in the tree each internal
party has an internal view of where we
are in the protocol tree and these
diverge without warning so so Bob's you
of where we are is on the left that the
one was sent and out analysis view is
that is that a zero was set so we need
some kind of mechanism to to detect
disagreement in the internally simulated
view of the transcript we need to
provide a mechanism to move them back
towards the point of agreement and once
there we think to try to proceed again
down down the protocol tree so all the
solutions that will see for interactive
coding follow this general framework
that we need some kind of mechanism for
Alice and Bob to detect that their
internal views are inconsistent a
mechanism to move back in a way that
gets them closer to the point where they
are their views diverged and then once
they arrive there to try to proceed down
the protocol tree and so when there are
not errors will make progress in moving
back towards agreement and then
proceeding down when there are errors we
may get further and further away but we
will control the pace of that so that
when there's a bounded constant rate of
error we can make enough progress that
will that will reach agreement at the
bottom of the tree so the way that
Schulman formulated this is to is to
think about these as pebble movement so
each bar party has a pebble that it
moves around the protocol tree to
represent where it believes in the
computation it is so we can use a simple
for simple Alf alphabet for the motions
of such a pebble on a binary tree it
either goes down into the left it goes
down into the right it goes up which
since we're in a tree
of say a circuit is an unambiguous thing
to go to go up and we also will have a
symbol for hold which is to stay to stay
put at your at your node in the tree the
reason for this is that we may have a
situation where parties are at different
levels of the tree because parties are
moving up in parties are moving down we
can get out of sync as to what lever
we're at in which case we want the guy
that's higher up to just sort of wait
for the other guy to come back to him so
we don't yes there are just two parties
later in the talk I'll talk about the
end party case but at the moment they're
just they're just two parties okay and
so we're going to describe how pebbles
move along one branch of the tree at a
time at most one branch or stay put and
so the reason that we're going to
stipulate that movement is very small so
you could imagine a case where because
there have been many errors parties are
really out of sync so one party is at
level 10 of the tree and one party's at
level 100 if you detect this if you sort
of have a momentary glimpse where you
see that this is the case you might be
tempted to have the guy that's all the
way down like jump all the way back this
would usually be a bad idea because this
view that you have could also be the
error it could also be that you're both
correct at a certain point and the
adversary makes you think that things
are way off so if you overreact if you
move if you try to correct a lot at once
you're vulnerable to the correction
itself being corrupted so there's
there's no safe moments there's no bits
that are assured to be right so we
always want to take very small cautious
movements so that on aggregate most of
them are in the right direction and we
and we will make progress but none of
them are too big so when we are wrong we
can only be wrong in a small in a small
way and so the goal is to communicate
the sequence of pebble moves so that
each party can can eventually know at
the end of the protocol exactly where
the other party's pebble is and that we
make progress and make it all the way
down the original protocol tree so we
can think of this in some sense as
related to like a streaming code problem
where we want to encode a dynamic
sequence of characters left right back
and hold so that it is decoded properly
the entire sequence so far we want to be
decoded properly at special moments in
time when there haven't been
too high a density of errors in the past
and the global guarantee is that by the
end of the protocol the end of the
protocol will be such a point in time
where the past sore obeys this relative
density of error bound so to do this
human but presented the first protocol
to do this and he used this very nice
combinatorial object called tree coats
so let me tell you how these things work
so a tree code looks confusingly like
the protocol tree but it's just but it's
a different tree so it's going to be a
binary tree and I'm going to label its
edges with numbers from some constant
size alphabet so in this case my off of
it is 1 2 3 4 5 and any to the the goal
of a tree code is to pick a labeling of
the edges such that any two paths in the
tree have a constant fraction of symbols
differing if i look at the portion of
the path from the lowest common ancestor
onwards so if i take an example here if
i look at these two paths the first the
first symbol is for is the same for both
of them just because they're traveling
along the same path so we don't we don't
count that we look at the sequence of
symbols after the paths diverge and we
get these two strings 1 2 5 and 3 to 4
which differ in italy in two out of
three symbols so this is the kind of
property we have for a tree code so note
that one thing that this immediately
implies is that two siblings of the same
parent we want there to be disagreements
in the string of length 1 so therefore
we can never have two edges that are
labeled exactly the same coming out of
coming out of the same node this is a
little bit of an annoyance because it
means that simply picking uniformly
random labels it doesn't work because
there's too high a chance of that
happening yes
the same baby yes it's possible for a
parent and a child to have the same
label yes okay any any other questions
about the the definition of this yes at
least constant fraction if I have more
disagreement that's great but I want
everything to be bounded from below by
the same constant fraction in the amount
of disagreement that I have other
questions so obviously if I could for
instance since i since I am allowing the
disagreement to be greater if I pick a
bigger alphabet my job gets easier right
in fact if I picked an alphabet
proportional to the size of the tree
this would be extremely easy it would
just give everything in Seoul maple so
the difficulty is getting is getting a
constant size alphabet for a tree of say
polynomial depths so so so that's the
challenge here and if I'm going to use
this inside an encoding protocol I also
would like there to be say an efficient
function to compute the label of a given
though okay so but let's suppose for a
moment that we had this kind of object
we that we had a 4 and x 4 area I don't
mean that the number of things in my
alphabet to label our four I mean that
I'm going to have instead of a binary
tree since I want to encode these four
possibilities i'm going to have a tree
code where my tree has four branches
coming out coming out of each of each
node and let's say that there's some
constant size alphabet that I can label
it and I can get a tree cope then I can
encode a sequence of these moves left
right back and hold by the labels of the
corresponding edges in the tree code so
i have my sequence of how I'm moving my
pebble and every time I want to make a
new move I'm at a certain point in the
tree code corresponding to the sequence
I've sent so far and now I simply send
the label of the edge corresponding to
my next movement so what I'm going to
send as an encoding of my sequence is
going to be the labels of a path down
the tree code where the path in the tree
code corresponds to my sequence of
pebble movements okay so while I'm going
back and hold and up and down in the
original protocol tree I'm
going marching down the tree code one
layer at a time always sending in next
symbol it at a new depth yes exactly so
Alice has has a Treecko to bob has a
tree code and they each send one one
symbol so Allison's a symbol Bob tries
to decode her sequence of pebble
movement see where she is decide where
he should go sends a new symbol and
history code and they go back and forth
they can be there tree codes can be the
same yes these tree cozy be generated
per communication protocol or no a fixed
tree code that is a tree code could be
used for all communication ever so yes
if there existed in nicely efficiently
computable tree code every protocol
could use it there's no importance to
like I don't need it to be unpredictable
I just needed to have this good distance
disagreement for PA's lot of distant
relative distance property other
questions so I'm thinking about the tree
code being on a for area tree so I have
four edges coming out of each node
corresponding to the four moves and I
send the label of the corresponding edge
I think I might have an example coming
up um maybe not so out of a hold right
if you just held in the in fact the tree
repeat that would have been under that
would be the left right of the parent
sibling son mouth yeah so so maybe let
me let me describe an example on this
for two let's say I don't use back on
hold i just use left and right so if i
use back and hold it's just that every
note here would have four edges coming
out but i would require the same
property on past so in my sequence of
pebbles i say okay at the beginning I
want to move left so i will i will send
a four because you're sending is you
yeah because i'm sending a zero in the
original protocol tree which is a
different tree than this but let's say I
decide okay it's the beginning of the
protocol my first bid is zero so i'm
going to move left so I send the label
of the left edge of my treat code now
we're here I receive something from the
other side the other person sends
something that moves me down in my
throat in my
call tree okay and maybe the next time I
am I want to move right so i send the
label in my tree code for a right move
you received something so that means
he'll remove no not in my tree code
might recall only corresponds to
encoding my sequence of moves in my
protocol tree so I have to I have two
trees I'm keeping track of where I think
i am in the simulated protocol that's
stepping from this this is just my tree
to encode my sequence of moves so I ok
so they match up at the beginning so I'm
sending the first bed i'm moving in both
trees now i receive a bit i move in the
protocol tree but i don't move in my
tree because this is just my encoding
now let's say based on what i heard i
want to move let's say right in the
protocol tree then i would send the
label corresponding to the right move
here now at some point based on what the
other person is saying when i'm in
decoding from their tree code which i
haven't described yet how we decode
let's say I decide that I want to move
back in the protocol tree then I move my
babble back in the protocol tree and I
still send a forward label edge here
there would be you know i would need
three options i would send the label
corresponding to the back motion in this
so i'm marching down this tree one
symbol at a time every time i'm trying
to send a pebble move yes unbalanced
because on the paths of the hole it's
much longer than on the path letting
winslet but let-let's this tree is a
perfectly balanced tree it's just what
portions of it i use or are do it is
perfectly balanced it only has to be as
long as the total bound on the
communication so if my original protocol
was a hundred rounds maybe my error
correcting protocol is going to be like
a constant times that lets say six
hundred rounds this has to be depth six
hundred and no and no longer yes I guess
I'm confused with the intuition about
why I should only keep track of my moves
on this tree because it sort of seems
like I know what my moves were usually
this is how do i encode to the other
party my move in a way that he
decode it when there are errors and
that's the idea of the tree code is that
he's going to look at the sequence of
symbols of tree code and if there aren't
too many errors he's at least going to
pick something that has a pretty good
common ancestor with what i actually did
so this is not about keeping track of
where i am this is about how do i
conveyed to him my sequence of moves in
a robust way ok if you decided to bet
fiddle then you don't choose left or
right which is one of those middle
branches and send the label of response
yeah so so this should be it's it's hard
to draw and actually be able to see this
should be a for Arri treat yes back then
you put the label corresponding to the
edge to that says yeah so there would be
like left right back hold and I would
send the label course but but I'm always
moving down in this tree where's my
pebble in the protocol tree is moving
back that's holding its doing these
different yes need another oh you
already said that number ok so I think
it'll I think it'll help a little if I
also talked about how the parties decode
and process the messages from other
people's last stupid questions yes sure
pittston anymore because I'm sending
things from this constant alphabet if I
want to send them as bits i can write
them in binary and it's up to the
constant factors but that's why I
constant alphabet right yes yes how many
trees are there and how many go there
there are there are two trees the
protocol tree and the end the tree code
I got for a courier why did the same
language is so encouraging my symbols
you have your triple but those could be
the same they could be the same almighty
you walk down your tree which is a
communication yes I
occasionally maybe we'll see a little
bit yes but I prefer to say there are
two trees and there are four views of
trees so there's a protocol tree we both
have our internal view of where we are
in it and there's a Treecko tree that
we're both sending our own set of
symbols down and your Treecko to my
trick code could be different but
there's no reason that they need to be
but i'm only sending my symbol moves and
you're only sending your symbol moves
okay other other questions okay so so i
said i'm sending symbols one at a time
down the tree code to encode the
sequence of pebble boobs in the original
thing and okay what do i do when i
receive such a symbol well I keep track
of the entire state the entire sequence
of symbols I've received from the other
party and I find the path in the other
party's tree code of the proper length
that has the closest Hamming distance
symbol by symbol to the path that I've
received so far okay so this is a brute
force inefficient decoding procedure as
I've defined it right but this is this
is a criterion for decoding I find the
path of the right link that has the
closest Hamming distance okay so one
technical point if I think about moving
in the protocol tree and I'm going to so
remember going to blow up the
communication by a constant since some
things are going to be wrong we're going
to need to move back may need to take
more time than just a first pass down
the protocol tree now if I just worked
into the original protocol tree with no
motivation with no modifications and I
get to the very end and then I hear
something that makes me go back and go
back I did adversary can win the game by
just waiting for the protocol to get to
the end and then moving me one node back
at the very end right so it's a little
bit silly so what we do is we had the
original protocol tree to have a bunch
of dummy notes simply for the reason
that a small error at the end it should
not actually move us off something that
we've been confirming for the last
however many rounds of communication so
we're going to work with a padded
protocol tree that's artificially longer
and just sends dummy messages under
under whatever leaf node so that when we
move a single a single node
of like an error at the end we're just
moving under the same dummy node of the
original trees so we don't get a
different answer and this is this is
just a technicality it's it's not very
hard to do but it's just so you realize
like okay any error can move the pebble
why is it not that the final pebble move
screws up the answer so this is yes
dummy layers do we need to add constant
you know it'll be a constant
multiplication with respect to the depth
so the original protocol tree will get
multiplied by a constant depth
selectively completely isn't it cool I
can think of it as an infinite protocol
and I use as much of it as I want right
so I don't hold at the end just because
I'm at the end essentially i keep sort
of computing sort of deeper down into
like dummy layers of this protocol tree
okay so intuition for for--why does this
work why is the tree code property a
sufficient property for getting the
right answer here so Shulman's analysis
is very as very instructive on this and
when he does is he defines a good event
as a moment when both parties correctly
decode and know where the other party's
peple is okay so if I have a moment
where the sequence of symbols that have
been sent in the other party's tree code
to me so far where the the path that has
a Smalling smallest Hamming distance is
actually the right path so I actually
get the right sort of node in the tree
code then I know the entire correct
sequence of pebble moves that they have
set okay if I'm at exactly the right
point in their tree code I know exactly
what their sequence of moves is laughter
I'd back hole etc so I know exactly
where their pebble is I can simulate
that entire sequence and I know exactly
where their pebble is so if both parties
correctly know where the other party's
pebble is but I'm going to claim that
they can make progress in this little
moment of time they can make progress
because they either agree on where they
are and they can move forward and make
forward progress in simulating the
protocol or they see that they've
screwed up and they can make progress
towards getting back to a point of
agreement where they can move forward so
if we define progress to be how much
have we agreed upon mine is how far
off are we from this moment where we can
go back and then to the last point of
agreement that we can make positive
progress in this measure at any point in
time where we correctly both know where
the other parties pebble is and a bad
event is a decoding error meaning that I
have picked the wrong node in the tree
code I have picked something that is not
the right sequence in the tree code and
in this and this okay can cause me to
make anti-progress the sense that I can
move my pebble in a way that's that's
not helpful right I can go back when I
didn't need to go back I can go forward
when I should have gone back I can go
back when I should have held etc but
this only cause is a bounded amount of
damage it only causes me to move like
one edge at a time so i only get a
constant an additive constant
anti-progress okay so if i look at these
moments in time where you have a
decoding error I can sort of classify
how bad such an event is by the depth of
the decoding error on the tree which is
what i mean is like how high up the tree
does it diverged from the correct
sequence the code tree absolutely yes so
I get this sequence of symbols in the
tree code ID code to the closest Hamming
distance I look at that of that point in
the tree compared to the real points in
the code tree and I look how far away is
the common ancestor of those paths and
that's a measure of how bad my decoding
my decoding error is so if I look behind
me if I have that I diverged like a
sequence of length D then I can I know
that there has to be a constant fraction
of wrong symbols in that recent past up
to the common ancestor right because the
property of the tree code is that if I
have a long divergence if I have a very
high common ancestor and then long pass
coming down in the tree code that I have
a lot of errors I have a lot of
inconsistencies along those paths so if
i have a decoding era of depth L so L is
how far away am i from the common
ancestor so a higher L means a higher
divert a hired point of divergence then
I can look behind the
there's an interval of time that's a cut
of lengths a constant times L that has a
constant fraction of errors okay so I
can sort of charge this bad moment to
the fact that in my recent past I've had
a constant density of errors and I can
set the parameters of the tree code such
that this constant density it's higher
than the global allowed average density
the adversary is allowed to spend which
means that these bad intervals cannot
cover too much of the total of the total
length of time yes no yes yes they do
and it needs to have a certain
relationship with the tree code bound so
we can only get so with this method we
can only get constant error rates for
which we can get tree codes they get
better Eretz than that yes principle you
could guess that or maybe try run are
the protocols with different ever right
yes i would say probably at least for
this approach we're going to see better
approaches with bit with better
constants but if this if we only had
shulman if there had not been all this
recent progress the more limiting factor
would be that you know he only he only
proves tree codes up to a constant of
like 1 over 256 so it's more like how do
i get treecko's for those good enough
constants more than it is guessing at
least at least in this framework but
there there's been much success on
getting on getting better constant so
hopefully have time to get to that a
little bit okay so um right so if we
have the parameters working out in the
right way we get that these bad
intervals can only cover a bounded
fraction of all time okay and when we're
not in a bad interval we know we're
making progress and when we are in a bad
interval we have one of these bad events
we're only making again a constant rate
of anti-progress so we can play these
constants off each other and we can make
progress on average and we can get to
simulate the correct the correct note of
our our protocol tree okay so so the so
that's essentially the analysis
yes I'm you and like it's wet when would
you ever send a hold or back i mean this
this wasn't quite explain so when so
when I'm decoding somebody else's
sequence of moves and so so let's say
Alice Allison's the first bit and she's
trying to send 0 but it gets hurt as one
right at some point she's going to
correctly decode Bob sequence of moves
and see that he simulated this this one
on his protocol tree that isn't right so
that point she's going to want to move
them back she's going to want to get him
to go back and his pebble is trying to
follow her pebble so she's going to move
her pebble back to convince him know we
need to go back to the top of the tree
and we simulate this because you moved
away that wasn't what I said and so she
sends back to try to try to she moves
her pebble back to get him to come back
to meet her so that they can go down
together so they're always trying to
keep their pebbles together and when I
send you a forward motion and you miss
hear it you're going to take your pebble
the wrong way the mechanism for me to
say it to speak up and correct that is
to move is to move the pebbles back to
the last point than we agreed and then
wait for you to catch up to me it's
protocol specific or something or if
there are messages that Alice could send
it it doesn't matter i doesn't care
about really what they say so this is
the this is the worst case where you
know the function that every message
depends upon the entire sequence of
previous messages which is you know
which covers all cases but there could
be protocols for which I could take
advantage of different structure but
this is for the jib for a general
protocol this will work for any for any
protocol but it won't be optimized for
every protocol yes I still confuse can
you specify exactly what about the
convoy well done it does in each step
and Bob does in each step so in each
step they they look at the Senate the
sequence of tree code symbols that
they've had that they've received in the
other person and they decode it to e 2 a
2 points in the tree the closest Hamming
distance and that corresponds to a
sequence of moves left right hold back
they simulate this to see where the
other person's pebble is in the protocol
tree and then they know where they are
pebble is in the protocol tree now if
they're not
the same place they want to get them
back to the same place so if my pebble
is below if I'm Alice and my pebble is
below Bob's I want to go back up to meet
him if I'm Alison my pebble is above
Bob's I want to hold and wait for him to
come back to me if we're in the same
place and it's my turn to speak I will
tell him which way to go forward ok yes
you go back to the previous life so is
this analysis ever using the length of
the interval or is it just using the
fact that there's only a constant
fraction of point in time in which
there's any interval yeah it does it
doesn't actually care about the length
of the interval
as I think so if you get with the
protocols have been different maybe
inputs has different communication
complexity by one even on the best input
conceivably can get the worst right so
on so I'm thinking about things in terms
of a fixed communication complexity that
covers all inputs right so yes it is
thank you thank you know if it's like
communication break something she's no
strings are not equal are the way or
something yeah so if you participant of
corners using a few more preserve the
what is going no it's it's not it's not
going to preserve that at least in in
the in the way that we're analyzing it
now whether you could or not I'm not I'm
not so sure i think is well I'm just
saying here is a technicality how you
count the number of Paris you you can
always say the doctor is always allowed
with the ghost of fractions a current
transmission as opposed to were skate
because he of course is reason yeah I
mean that's not it's not equivalent in
the sense that yeah it makes the problem
easier because it's more of a constraint
on the attacker so in that model you
could hope to preserve more
communication rates but yeah I'm not
working in that model okay so hopefully
now I've given you a little appreciation
for that tree codes or our powerful
entry codes are cool a bit of bad news I
have no idea how to efficiently
construct them okay so there there has
been some progress on this and and i
should say there's also some nice
progress on tree codes that can correct
noisy errors by gala say hi and moira
that that looks at a relaxation of the
tree code that helps us get efficient
constructions but for bed for
adversarial errors we still at least
with this approach we still seem to need
tree codes that we can't efficiently
construct and randomized constructions
are known but we still want efficient
decoding to yes yes they have compact
representations but they don't have
efficient decoding procedures so you
still have to do this brute force
hamming having distance thing which is
not polynomial time in general okay so
there isn't a tree code construction yes
exponentially fun no yeah it's it's also
a polynomial only polynomial a small
chance of the Treecko just not being a
tree cook yes but even I'm even if we
say we're willing to live with okay
something it has ninety percent chance
of being a tree code and we want
efficient decoding we don't have such we
don't have such a construction uh so
amazing though cryptographers to the
rescue sobra Kirksey and collide in 2012
notice that you actually don't need
these long tree codes so what's hard
about a tree code why is eco is a
decoding inefficient for for these
randomized construction well it's
because the tree codes are long you know
I can brute force a Hamming code on
constant size drinks a or logarithmic
size strings so if we revisit this
higher level of approach what do we
really need from this we need a
mechanism to detect disagreement we need
a mechanism to move back toward
agreement and we need a mechanism once
precinct to to encode progress down down
the protocol tree okay so as
cryptographers when we look at bullet
one provide a mechanism to detect
disagreement something should should
jump out immediately at us which which
is not a tree code but it's just a hash
function right collision collision
resistant hash so so here's the
observation of Bricker ski and collide
we can build short tree codes by brute
force in polynomial time okay so we can
sort of naively concatenate them as a
first step we can use tree code one for
a while and then start over and use tree
CO 2 which could be the same tree code
it doesn't really matter it's just that
we're starting fresh on a new on a new
tree code that's very short we're going
to run out we're going to need to swap
it out and do a new one and so on what's
what's the problem why can't I just
stack little tree codes on top of each
other well it doesn't actually yield
long treat code we know we know that and
so we lose the ability to detect and
correct errors in the more distant past
okay so if a adversary injects errors
all the way down in particular tree code
and then you start over encoding the
sequence and a new tree code you have no
way of knowing that you're starting from
the wrong place what your encoding now
tells you nothing about the errors that
have happened in the past okay so we we
end up losing memory of things that we
need to still correct in the more
distant past so but to detect things in
the past instead of in the present we
can simply use use a use a hash so we
can hash the entire simulated transcript
so far to protect to detect any
lingering disagreement in the in the
past when we swap out for a new tree
code okay so this is kind of what the
broker squeakily protocol looks like i
divided the original protocol in the
smallest chunks it's a logarithmic size
chunks let's say and I use a short tree
code to try to simulate each one and now
now I do a hash of everything so far to
decide am I happy are we in agreement
with what we simulated or do we want to
go back sort of an entire chunk at a
time okay so we change from these
motions of pebble to pebble and we sort
of have this more general motion of
chopped to chunk and where we try to
simulate a chunk internally we're doing
the tree code thing and the chunk but
we're doing it in a local in a local way
that we can sort of brute force
computationally efficiently and then we
do a hash to see if we want to sort of
go forward and do a new chunk or go back
and redo an old chunk in which in which
there's been disagreement ok so the
properties that they used to do their
analysis are they want their hash length
to be long enough to avoid collisions
with high probability if you avoid
collisions with high probability over
the course of a lifetime in the protocol
then it's very easy to analyze because
you can simply do a Union bound over the
bad events that there being any kind of
collisions in the hash and you can
analyze a hash where these the case
where these hashes always detect all the
disagreements but notice that we don't
so we want somewhat long hashes to avoid
collisions but we also don't want to
blow up the total communication more
than
constant factor so the balance that that
we want to strike is that these hash
faces when I send so when I send across
the hash of my value to the other person
so that we can try to check and see if
we agree the communication from that
shouldn't overwhelm the communication
from simulating the regular protocol
because i don't want more than a
constant multiplicative overhead so so
the balance that they strike is that the
total communication of these chunks will
match the length of the hash so that
these phases are from equally weighted
so the amount of communication i spend
simulating the protocol is going to be
proportional up to a constant factor to
the amount of communication i spend
doing these hashes okay and since I want
hashes to be somewhat long like
logarithmically long to prevent
collisions I also want my chunks to be
sort of logarithmic size but I can brute
force a tree code so that those at those
parameters so I get an efficient
protocol that as a with high probability
success yes mark with a hash to write oh
yes absolutely yeah so the hat so let's
so it's kind of a one-way error in the
sense that let's say that the hashes
don't so wait there's two ways that he
can do this if the hash doesn't agree he
can make it look like a degrees right
but to do that so that's gonna so what
is that going to make you do it's going
to make you go forward and do a whole
chunk of before you get another chance
at noticing that you disagree right so
it sort of cost you one additional chunk
before you have an opportunity to
correct this again but the number of
errors he has to introduce so i should
say here and i didn't say when i'm
sending a hash it's a long message right
i can wrap it in an error correcting
code so the number of errors he has to
introduce to to muck with the hash is
proportional to the length of that just
proportional to the length of a chunk so
the amount of anti-progress that I make
is proportional to the rate of eros he
injects so I can still make forward
progress so when he we need when he does
something wrong with the hash he has to
pay for proportional to a chunk size and
after another chunk I get another
opportunity to correct
so the mount he throws me off by is
proportional to his budget of errors so
I can play the cost and saw each other
and still and still make average
progress photos it be this chunk the
hash key can be picked freshly random
every time and sent along with the
error-correcting code at the hash at the
hash face he's a famous children no I
don't need to and it'll be unpredictable
to him every time other questions about
this yes so if you have to what are you
passion or part of the what you saw an
innocent so I'm hashing what I where I
think we are in the protocol tree so my
simulated transcript so I've so I've
gone left right left right and I and I'm
trying to tell him I think we're here
right that's that's what I hash yes no
partners hit have access to shared
randomness or it's no no yeah in this
model there's there's no there's no
shared randomness each one simply picks
a fresh key for a hash every time and
sends that key protected in the
error-correcting code along with its
with his hash value doesn't get much
that about oh yes my specialism is
possible you can't talk to anonymize yes
I don't know how it's not known how to
do randomized this protocol so the open
question sort of between this and the
end the tree code version the tree code
once I picked a tree code so if i use a
randomized construction of a tree code
that's randomized but once I've picked a
tree code the schumann protocol is
deterministic okay so this does not this
protocol does not settle the question
does there exist a polynomial-time
deterministic protocol but it's pretty
good i mean you can get it to succeed
with with high probability generate
here's a quarter um I don't think that's
true i think it's a little worse than
that but it was better than Shulman's if
i recall yeah it's i don't think it's
known to be optimal there i mean talk
about some recent work of ha ha plur
that deals with more more optimal
Constance no you don't you don't
universal hash yeah everything is
information theoretic if I'm if I just
have the party to take fresh randomness
for the hash keys every time this is an
information-theoretic property still I
don't need yeah I don't need to
introduce computational assumptions okay
so so let me tell you a bit of this
surprise that sort of happens after you
stare at this protocol for a bit so this
is saying okay I don't need long tree
code so i can i can use hashes right but
i still have these brute force these
fruit four steps what's guess there
Polly time but it's not sort of the most
elegant or the quickest or the simplest
protocol that that I can hope to do so
sort of what's very funny to me is that
you know it's very easy to stare at this
and think that the hashes need to be
long so that you avoid collisions and if
hashes need to be long than chunks need
to be long because you need to have this
this kind of balance ah but i think the
sort of the beginning for for the
starting point for for new work of
poplars that came out in 2014 so you
don't really need these even these short
tree codes at all we can have a much
more more elegant protocol and and the
main observation is hash collisions are
not so bad okay there's really no reason
we have to bend over backwards to make a
hash collision a negligible event that I
can certainly understand where Bakr ski
& Co liar coming from it's my very
initial tendency to like let's just
think them long enough that it never
happens and we never have to think about
it right we do it all the time but hash
collisions are not so bad it's kind of
the same as an error right we're already
dealing with a constant error rate
whether it happens because of a hash
collision or an attack on the air crack
you know we're flipping enough bits in
the are correcting code or disrupting
the chunk simulation itself we're
already dealing with errors why not try
to absorb hash collisions at a constant
rate as just another constant rate
source of error okay and then we can
make the chunks constant size and we
don't even need short tree codes
okay and since independent hash keys are
picked every time we can still use
really powerful concentration balance
like chair enough bounds to suitably
control the overall density of the hash
collisions and get nonetheless a very
nice bound on the simulation progress
yes even if you want the cashes constant
size the pesky can also be made constant
size it will also be constant size
because I'm going to allow a constant
probability of collision assume you'll
make you like evolution co-sponsor then
I using a 3 4th or so different maybe
this like adjust time I have thought
about that a lot and I cannot see how to
derive it recode out of these
constructions we I think a lot of us
would would love to see that and we
don't know we don't know how it seems
more like we are separating these
problems in the at least in the
randomized setting from tree codes we do
not know how to extract treecko's from
these techniques and there is and there
does seem to be at least one explanation
which is that we are using the fresh
randomness of these hash keys every time
Treecko doesn't have a deterministic
Treecko doesn't have that kind of that
kind of flexibility yes if you're going
to say this but you saw on the issue of
trying to figure out how about you know
which what's the nearest Hamming weight
kosher so how did you got to go back I'm
search over the possible no actually so
so when when my chunks are constant
length I'm not even going to need if I
don't care about the constant rates if
I'm just saying I get a constant rate I
have a constant rate of air and a
constant multiplicative overhead
actually don't even need to do error
correction within the chunk simulations
at all so if a chunk is a 10 bits
exchanged back and forth then I just let
them all happen as if they're error-free
and then I hash to see if we agree or
not so anyone bit error injected into
that 10 bits will send me off but I'm
just going to make the error rate
smaller than one-tenth now that that's
constant I can just make the error rate
smaller than the chunk size so that he
can't even afford to pay one bit per
chunk because the chunk size is constant
so his area can be bounded below with
respect to the chunk size and
I don't actually have to protect I don't
have to decode anything I just run the
thing as if it's error-free for a small
amount of time I do hashes to correct
and and again now the hash size is also
cost of link so I don't even need to
wrap them in an error correcting code
although I should so I can get better
constants right but yes need so you
detect now that you know so you disagree
that then how do you fix it yes
excellent question so this is the thing
I'm hiding under the rug because I don't
want to get mired in the details of his
of his protocol because it's it it's
much more than this this is one in sight
of it but he does a lot more and he also
talks about optimal constants but the
tricky thing is here right like when the
chunks are when the hashes are allowed
to be longer we could also afford to in
the hash phase say communicate with an
error correcting code an index of what
chunk we think we're at so that we know
like if we're out of saying who should
go back and who should and who should
hold here if we're just sending
constants we can't afford to send an
index for where we should go back to
because the number of chunks can be
super constant so Bernard has a has a
more complex procedure for dealing with
this where we sort of vote on where we
think we are and we use more bits of
communication to do that but everything
stays within a constant rate I'm just
not going to go through that procedure
because it's more complicated than I'd
rather get to interactions of this kind
of thing with other applications rather
than go through but excellent question
yes it does get more complicated to
figure out who should go back when you
don't have enough communication to send
an index yes other other questions about
this so this to me is kind of shocking
that we've gone from schulman in the 90s
showing us these beautiful things with
tree codes that we had no idea to
construct so somehow realizing in 2014
that we didn't need them in the first
place like at all and there's still
beautiful mathematical objects I'm sure
we will still see work on trying to and
it is also the D randomization question
so tree codes are a potential way of D
randomizing that we don't know another
way to do at this point but this
protocol is kind of amazing to me yes
sorry
yeah yeah and everything so information
theoretic I don't need any computational
assumptions and I can even there smells
even been progress on like the best
constants that you can achieve in things
like this Jenny deterministic particle
would give you a drake road I don't know
that no it's an interesting question but
yes I I don't know the answer to that
okay so so now so now that we have these
really great efficient rather simple
kinds of protocols i wanna i want to end
by talking about what kind of
applications might might we use this for
and how does this topic of interactive
coding sort of intersect with crypto and
other things okay so this is a simulated
protocol so let me tell you a little bit
about interactive coding meets
cryptography so we can ask this question
of what happens if we want to apply this
kind of thing in interactive protocols
where we want to preserve more than just
correctness and roughly communication
complexity ok so the sudden we've been
talking about so far is if we want the
parties to get the right answer and we
don't want them to have to communicate
for too long but we haven't preserved
any other pieces of the protocol like
you know you can imagine settings like
secure multi-party computation where yes
I want to get the right answer but I
also want to preserve secrecy and
privacy of my input right so other
things you might want to preserve so
there's been some work on this say the
definition of knowledge preserving
interactive coding which which tried to
sort of to sort of look at this
holistically and say can we ensure that
parties don't learn anything more about
the others input then they would have
learned in the error-free setting okay
so this is a question that's relevant to
say if you could do this this would
immediately allow you to apply this to
say secure multi-party computation or
some such settings and the answer was no
at least not with the with the constant
error rate and the main intuition is
that this back tracking mechanism if we
think about what we're doing we're sort
of allowing errors to give someone
another query at the next message
function right so by going back you get
to see what they would have said and it
different situation so you get to sort
of probe this other party at more points
in the potential protocol tree than a
straight path down yes it's just for
information theoretic so you can imagine
lots of computational solutions to this
problem that work actually quite well so
for instance just signing every message
and only answering things when they're
signed can sort of force you to only
tank so computationally this problem as
much it's much nicer but information
theoretically which everything so far
has been information theoretic we can't
do this with it with a good error rate
of course we can if we were willing to
take the sort of one over a number of
rounds hit in the error rate we can
protect each round with an error
correcting code and refuse to go back so
with rate 1 over m we we can do it but
but otherwise information theoretically
we can't but interests yes in the usual
sense doesn't quite work because signing
message is at least K bits of security
and so you immediately if you sign every
message and the message is that small
you immediately paying k cost of society
right so yeah so there there is there is
some overhead and it's not it's not the
error rate that goes up but there is
some overhead in the communication
that's additive in the security
parameter but so so this message is
Haven one bit but scientists one message
requests k beats of a signature key so
you are going yeah you are going to pay
for the security perimeter so I don't
remember exactly what the parameter
trade-off is but but they look at this
in the paper and they work out a
computational solution that has
reasonably good parameters but so I'm
going to talk a little bit about what we
still can do information theoretically
so I want to tell you a little bit about
our result for I p equals P space over
adversarial channels so you can ask for
a little bit less then this knowledge
preserving thing is kind of like almost
like a vb be kind of result right it
feels like it should be impossible
because you're asking for a lot you're
asking for them to learn nothing
ditional so we can look at settings
where there are specific things we want
to hide but we don't want to hide
everything and in this case we can get
information theoretic solutions so we
can think for instance about the problem
of I p equals P space over an
adversarial channel okay so let's see it
lets consider for this case that I have
a verifier and approver and in the error
free setting you know the verifier sends
challenges in the prover provides
responses okay and an IP you know we we
have these protocols that have many
rounds so simply protecting things with
an error correcting code is not going to
give a sort of constant rate resilience
because we have a super constant number
of rounds of challenge and response yes
yes I'd be without the stereo channels
so far or completeness and soundness yes
yeah so I'm going to define the the
complete list and the soundness yes but
that is what I mean so if I'm now trying
to do this proven verifier a protocol
over a channel that has this adversarial
noise at a constant rate then I could
say simply plug in an interactive coding
protocol on top of a roof system but I
might be concerned that I could lose so
I've said that will preserve correctness
in that case right I'll compute exactly
the same answer I would have computed so
I would preserve that the verifier would
accept honest proofs if I if I did that
concatenation of things but I would not
necessarily preserve soundness because
now the prover can use channel errors as
an excuse to back up the verifier and
not answer challenge you didn't want to
answer right let's see there's one
challenge that you know the verifier is
going along he makes challenge a
dishonest poker doesn't know how to
respond let me say you know I can't
can't hear you I didn't hear you go back
right so so we're worried here about so
we already know in some sense how to
preserve correctness how to make it so
that an honest proveer can still get
verified if we use interactive coding
but we don't know how to preserve
soundness necessarily like why can a
cheat improver not use the
use of channel errors to convince the
verifier of a false statement yes I'm
the lion is Robert distribution of Allah
I go to China waiver so I don't make any
assumptions about the distribution of
channel error it's allowed to be
adversarial any constant fraction of the
total communication so I find is a big
country intuitive evidence it's the
other way around soundness is trivia
because if the string is not in the
language and the kruger cannot convince
the verify ever any channel errors are
not going to convince the very power
read while left but i have to change
completeness follows from the from the
interactive coding so the thing is like
yeah because i need to modify the
protocol to preserve cret so as you say
can think of this as a two-step process
I'm going to need to modify modify the
protocol to preserve correctness and the
problem is how do i do that modification
without destroying soundness absolutely
yes it's not that you don't like your
challenge is that you're not you don't
want to commit to something that you
have seen yeah it's also that right I
can also say oh you misheard my my
response yes yes indeed completeness and
stamina so when you apply the IQ level
protocol where is it because San this is
only probabilistic and the radius is
perfect order so you mean why this just
applying an interactive and arbitrary
interactive coating on top of the yeah I
don't know how to I don't know how to
show that Colette massif both parties
triumph is a good
exactly yeah yeah mmhmm yeah because now
the prover can use what he's seen
because of the coding errors you know to
purposely move the challenges in a
certain direction yeah it doesn't it
doesn't preserve the distribution on
transcripts is the thing like the
approver now has control over the
transcript in a way it did it before so
it changes the distribution on
transcripts that are produced okay but
even though the the sort of natural
concatenation doesn't work we can
actually so it turns out we can do this
so we can for sort of Craig nurse and
soundness / / adversarial errors
essentially using exactly just the same
kind of lightweight techniques of
hashing and checking that that we can
that we can use to do to do general
interactive coding so the main idea is
like what do we have on our side so we
know we can't do this general knowledge
preservation but we do know that when we
go back we know we're going back so when
the prover says let's rewind let's go
back let's do a new challenge the
verifier knows what's happening and you
can use fresh randomness and we can use
a application to prevent say like a
polynomial number of backtracks to
really give the prover enough additional
advantage okay so we can sort of mute
the control of the / / / the / the
transcripts by taking fresh randomness
every time we go back and and also using
a hardness amplification so that say
getting sort of like a polynomial number
of retries the challenges doesn't
actually give him success in convincing
us of a false statement
yeah so if if it's not a public coins
protocol there you will incur loss and
transforming it into a into a public
coins protocol for this so the so the
trade-off of the rates you will get will
be will be worse can you go the encode
any interactive protocol when reserving
decisions yeah um yes yeah this can work
for an arbitrary arbitrary interactive
protocol the error the error rate is a
constant yes what is the constant I
honestly don't remember at all yes mr.
just their MP okay more than a few
seconds what do you do that just a
disappearing finger just just make sure
they welcome their sons to make sure
that you will catch him in many many
cases and use your knowledge just sent
ya an anything that doesn't need a super
constant number of rounds I just use an
error correcting code and I'm fine yeah
it has to be a super that's the need of
super casa number of rounds to this
problem yes yes can the prover make
things last forever no I'm still going
to pick a fixed protocol length and only
run for that amount of time and then and
that also bounds the number of errors
that as a fraction of that he's willing
to do yes yes
I have no idea I haven't thought about
it London issue here right verifier
knows that he has to go back I mean it's
not like he's being rebound and he
doesn't know sorry yeah no 1 i'm do but
this is for you can sing yeah this is
I'm just saying I don't need yeah I can
get around needing then kind of explicit
yeah the first but we do use the fact
that you know you're being rewound I
think which makes which makes things
cleaner I one thing I don't know it's
like for at this question there is this
kind of historical kind of backlash
surfacing for attractive quitting people
you know really care about this course
and a song but I easily this for bateria
concepts like one starts to serve which
academies are constants so talking about
the you know exact constants when you
introduce these are constant since the
definition is not played such a
meaningful thing but but it's going to
in sofla make so much more than yeah
well that affects exactly every it's not
effects these constants and I mean the
relationships are not that law see our
constants are not that bad but I don't
remember what they are okay so I'm
running out of time so I'm going to
conclude but I do just want to say like
there's a bunch of interesting
applications further on for instance to
multi-party protocols so you could
imagine that this gets a lot more
interesting in the multi-party case
because I have more than two people that
I need to sync up now that I've end
people and there's an error and steps
sort of need to happen in sync to
correct it so we can look at how these
things scale with n we can look at
different different models of
communications so there's been so
there's been a lot of work on this in in
multiparty protocols so I'm not going to
go I'm not going to go through this but
the main idea is how do i sync up
parties and sort of reduce to to the
pairwise computations and what kind of
what kind of protocols can I get in
terms of efficiency so so I want to
conclude on a more speculative
connection sort of wondering how all of
this once we get to the multi-party
setting wondering how all this sort of
relates to more general distributed
computing against adversarial errors so
recently there was this beautiful
protocol of thing in
King in tsaia for expected poly time
Byzantine agreement against a
computationally unbounded adaptive
asynchronous adversary so it gets a
really worst case adversary so this is I
think actually a beautiful problem for
cryptographers because we're very
naturally pessimistic people who aren't
you know content with sort of
constraints on synchrony and constraints
on adversaries and this I think is the
first thing that gets close to an
understanding of what is really the
worst case adversary against which we
can do distributed computations so this
is sort of getting close to that ah but
one feature of their protocol so I
present an impossibility result that
they have it still static corruptions of
individual parties so parties that
aren't corrupt are always perfect in
their communication so I would like
something more that looks like a mobile
adversary that corrupt certain parties
at certain times but can eventually be
everywhere on the network so I like to
consider a sort of adversary that that
corrupts a changing set of players and I
show under a certain model of this that
you can't do this but the more
intriguing question is ok I can think
about a mobile adversary as a network
adversary as errors on the channels sort
of more globally in the protocol and I'd
like to ask the question average aerial
channels can model each of these kinds
of adversaries of corrupting parties and
corrupting moving parties and just more
general adversary's so possible to
classify the worst-case adversarial
network against which Byzantine
agreement is possible so I think
interactive coding for multiple parties
has some interesting directions that we
can go both in terms of looking at it
maybe in the crypto setting and like
secure multi-party computation is people
are joining but also in these more
general settings of like what are really
worst worst case adversaries against
which we can hope to get the these kind
of coordinated distributed computations
so I'd like to stop there thanks any
further questions
yeah just uh just I guess the table
bored with the difference between the
new day work and so it was pretty
obviously people were to use for cash
functions you only want to make the
chunks length is exactly because you
need to know where you are so not the
chunk number something like that that's
the only reason why you needed to be
long right shows like a very nice way on
how to sort of try to keep track of da
the only source any little bit little
bits of information right this sort of
cue track of that in a more distributed
way yet this is where the word along
some stuff so I understand the emissary
a bottle for the two part of cases the
answer is only allowed to change symbols
to introduce symbols are a symbol for
channel we try to cause the party to get
out of sync yes although actually once
we get to the point of the hashing that
can that can sort of reset where you are
they can sort of keep track of where you
are it is really this we do believe it
is resistant to insertion of symbols as
well because the thing about like in the
tree code approach this seemed this
seems to go outside the definition of
the tree code because the guarantee is
only four strings at exactly the same
level of the tree so when you decoding a
string of the wrong length you might
expect that it should kind of be a
recoverable error but the Treecko
definition says nothing explicitly about
this but once we get to the hashing you
know I can hash things of different
lengths and I'll detect that they're
different lengths and they disagree so
we do believe that these things can be
adjusted to do that do you think that
equals actually a full month don't worry
Freddy distance if you have a constant
fraction of that errors they're not
defined to they may or may not but the
guarantee that he proves is that things
that exactly the same level of tree have
this property he does not prove anything
about strings of different links you
just admitted a paper sword of his mark
Braverman Angeles extending the
definition of treecko's to any distance
and everything you would expect to go
through does grow stronger yeah it's
just not it that's not it it's not an
obvious thing from the properties of
children troops at all yeah
you find what it means to quadrillions
they think the course actually work
identified recall 20 distance you can
construct them and this popular thing
also want something everything yeah yeah
I don't want to it's also not explicitly
it's also not explicitly done in hablar
but the techniques are relatively robust
to be synced once you don't have this
explicit requirement that looks at
exactly things of the same length it
seems it seems possible to to do this
yes are you satisfied with any binomial
no no no not any polynomial constant
constant multiplicative factor of
communication so if I start with the
protocol of em rounds I want a final
protocol 10 and rounds not M Squared if
you guys going to communication but not
number of pounds though the same thing
if I'm looking at if I'm looking at
rounds that have the same number of bits
they're the same thing okay let's thank
this video game